when you hear the word budgeting they go
to Saturday
I gotta mean savings doesn't mean
anything else sitting with a plan the
case of this cementation for the future
anything else you guys announcer that
your money efficiently organizing your
money efficiently fantastic Jonah had
something that is something different
okay like how much can I spend on okay
great
all of these ideas are exactly right let
me try and tie them together in a nice
neat burger okay
budgeting is about the one thing that
balances all the things you said to get
up is actually the word balance it's
about balancing two particular
quantities okay money coming in and
money going out we call these income and
expenses okay simple simple idea so
income as you can tell by the name this
is money in and expenses are money out
before we move any further let's just
think about this for a second money in
there are only really two categories of
things that we know about that we bring
money into your account
the most obvious one which we've been
looking at a whole bunch of examples is
like you're gonna you've got a job right
so you've got earnings right however
over the last couple of hours we've also
noticed there are ways to get money and
have nothing to do with burning and
actually having a job what do they call
it yeah allowance systems up to youth
allowance of the pensions etc so
earnings and allowances here a couple of
others but this is basically year okay
this is where money is going to come
into you what are you talking about
expenses okay money Allen there are a
lot of do this would you guys give me
some examples what
you guys actually spending money food
food was the first thing on my list too
I had to pray so some things food what
else you got for me Clady okay food plan
I also have that one down cancer this is
interesting right so obviously we could
make this this really really mold some
of these ideas though and they're kind
of it's sort of biker gets into to set
that is there are things you have to do
regularly right it's like I'm different
every day I have to eat every month my
friend is gonna like company's name
Chaudhary and then they're kind of like
bigger ticket items like a can they know
regular things but that you come around
every male in there so I'm just gonna
call those larger items okay cuz that's
pretty good okay
activities okay so I don't that cares we
talked about if you guys sport or
something like that all these kinds of
things
I'm money going I put on to their like
social stuff president yeah so you're
gonna buy presents me we're gonna go see
Deadpool whatever yes and these are all
the sensors now this idea of balancing
income and expenses right money and
should be on the list
yeah it's a bit disturbing it's like
this is all I've been coming in all of
these things coming out now the simple
idea here is there are two hours you can
make my ex where's the most common one
is overspending right it's where you're
blending in is it sufficient for your
money out okay so I'm just gonna jump
this one forever so Aaron number one
overspending I know
so overspending is where your income is
less than your expenses that's not a
good position to be in
ok this is good this is important this
is probably the main theme that most of
us have to worry about particularly at
your age where you don't have actually
German of income right but there is
every time there is an error in the
world there is always an error from
doing the same thing but backwards over
compensating okay what are the opposite
of overspending bit okay don't you call
it under suspended right in reality what
we're all talking about is look it's
like okay I know I need to say she just
say like everything okay if you save
everything that's really good for your
bank account but it's actually like if
you have a look at some of the money to
just answer your banks it is not nearly
the best way to use your money okay
you'll end up with like a fat back to
campus look doing it okay so what we
were cool this is this but it's under
utilization so this is where you're
getting all of is income but you're not
using it effectively it's just kind of
sitting there like underneath my bed
gathering dust it's not it's not
achieving anything for me
so the bank is going to give you
interest right right
my number one it's not that much number
two it's not it's not free money because
what the bank does is it's just imagine
just imagine all the people just okay if
we took all our savings and put it in
Python you're gonna have no matter from
it's not that your mom your goat you
have a pile of some size and you can do
stuff with that money
right until you say take me and just
like me and my focus is friends from
high school
hey yeah just like if you have a savings
upload you could like start a business
you could like invest in real estate
probably some we're just gonna make way
more than just like the measly whatever
4% 5% interest in the bank he's gonna
hate us you were just kidding in the
county well it depends on the incumbent
you have correct so I guess what I'm
saying here is under utilization is the
other situation it's where it's not just
what income is more than expenditure
it's where income is like way more than
your expenses right so it's like okay
look okay kid wants money here you won't
be able to use it effectively now
immediately the main problem that like I
said you guys are going to be interested
in and therefore these questions I
interested in is problem number one okay
so aratoon will not really come up with
as much but real life toes this is
something you need to be
when you stop making significant amounts
of money one of the other opportunities
all right now these questions what they
will often do is ask you to prepare a
budget that's what they're asking
okay and what goes into a budget is
three things in fact we already have two
of them on here okay I mean one will
write this now out of me
to make a budget you need three things
money okay now what I mean is the
question would say prepare a budget for
some answer with no give you some
information about them when they say
prepare a budget that's the occurred for
saying okay King Tomi these three things
and like I said we're burning up to the
two main ingredients on the board right
I indeed not to be confused with an
improvised explosive device
all I mean is can you tell me the income
can you tell me the expenses all up and
then the most critical piece can you
tell me the difference between them
obviously we want the income to be more
than defense is that like how much what
kind of provision for saving is that
going to provide for us
so I D income expenses the difference
between them that's all they need
that's all they asked me beautiful news